[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
résilience des territoires il y a plus
le choix la maison brûle disait déjà en
2002 jacques chirac au sommet de la
terre à johannesburg
la prise en compte de l'impact
climatique sur nos sociétés ne peut pas
être retardé si nous voulons pérenniser
des objectifs de développement durable
une croissance équitable et des modes de
vie qui ne soit pas trop contraint par
le réchauffement climatique
la prise de conscience écologique et
environnementale est partagée de tous ou
presque même si les résultats se font
attendre
les nations et les populations sont
aujourd'hui engagés dans une transition
énergétique fortement décarbonés avec le
concours
contrastée des industries des
institutions nationales et
internationales
publiques et privées c'est au niveau des
territoires de tous les territoires
urbains et ruraux maritime et terrestre
que s'opère cette transition qui croise
à la fois l'innovation la modernisation
des régulations des transitions et une
pertinence sociale seulement ce
mouvement résolument novateur a subi
deux années de crise sanitaire avec le
co vide qui ont bouleversé les
équilibres économiques biologique
industriels et financiers
à cela s'ajoute une nouvelle crise une
nouvelle tension avec le conflit russo
ukrainien qui met à mal les équilibres
démographiques et de sécurité
alimentaire avec de nouvelles migrations
massives et imprévus et quelques risques
de famine avec quelles conséquences sur
la dynamique territoriale et pour quel
résilience des territoires pour en
parler je vous présente mes invités
hélène peskine vous êtes architecte
urbaniste
secrétaire permanente du puca qui dépend
du ministère de l'écologie hervé gaymard
cet ancien ministre vous êtes président
du conseil départemental de savoie
nicolas meyer rossignol vous êtes maire
de roi et président de la métropole de
rouen sébastien maire vous êtes délégué
général de france ville durable
[Musique]
actualité oblige nous venons de vivre
deux années de qu'ovide et poursuivre ce
conflit russo ukrainien
sans lien entre les deux après la
rupture des chaînes d'approvisionnement
pendant le coc vide des impératifs de
sécurité de défense se pose depuis
l'invasion de l'ukraine dans ce contexte
sans être abandonné peut-on maintenir le
rythme de la transition écologique au
niveau des territoires notamment d'un
transition énergétique hervé gaymard
il faut même accéléré non seulement
maintenir mais accéléré et moi je suis
frappé par le foisonnement des
initiatives qui existent partout en
france dans les villes dans les
intercommunalités les départements et
les régions pour prendre en compte et
accélérer c'est indispensable
mutations notamment dans un domaine qui
d'ailleurs plus de la compétence des
départements mais j'en parle quand même
ce qu'il est majeur qui est celui des
transports et de l'organisation des
déplacements qui relève à la fois des
agglomérations des intercommunalités des
régions nous au niveau départemental ce
que l'on fait bien évidemment c'est
accélérer le développement du
déplacement
cyclables et au delà des routes
départementales d'aidé les traversées de
vie les développements dans le détail
hde à aller de l'avant c'est votre point
de vu aussi nicolas mais rossignol en
tant que maire de rouen accélérer ou
stabilisés
quand vous êtes dans le brouillard si
vous êtes sur une mer d'huile dans le
brouillard dans un bateau qu'est ce que
vous faites vous soit vous bougez pas et
puis vous attendez que le brouillard se
dissipe
soit vous garder un cap et vous essayez
de sortir du brouillard vous êtes marin
un petit peu mais franchement je
conseille pas d'aller sur un bateau avec
moi je vais pas vous qu il en est bien
loin non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'effectivement je suis d'accord sur
l'idée que
dans un contexte aussi difficile il faut
préserver une vision mais j'ajouterai
quand même deux choses qui sont pas
antinomiques avec ce que vient de dire
avec marc du tout mais simplement pour
compléter d'abord un les crises
sanitaires est liée au contexte
ukrainien en conflit ukrainien provoque
des innovations et des accélérations on
l'a très bien vu avec le vélo pendant la
crise sanitaire par exemple aujourd'hui
avec la hausse des prix des carburants
chez nous on a développé le covoiturage
on n'est pas les seuls l'agglomération
rouennaise est aujourd'hui la première
de france sur le développement du
covoiturage et ça c'est très directement
liée à l'inflation est la hausse des
prix des carburants la deuxième chose
qu'il faut vraiment avoir à l'esprit je
crois c'est qu'il ya un risque
d'étirements elle fut pas un risque
c'est une réalité d'étirements du corps
social entre des personnes qui peuvent
suivre le rythme parce qu'elles en ont
les moyens notamment financiers
mais pas uniquement et puis on l'a bien
vu avec les gilet jaune on le voit
aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on appelle les et
des feux les zones à faibles émissions
qui concerne toutes les grandes
agglomérations de france en réalité avec
ce rapport du giec qui me dit qu'on a
que trois ans pour agir et c'est un
risque de voir des territoires et des
personnes exclues et c'est là où on a
besoin je pense que les collectivités
avec les tapas contre l'état et ensemble
agissent beaucoup plus fortement donc ça
milite là aussi pour accélérer mais sur
la dimension sociale et par écologique
pas uniquement une écologique est ce que
vous l'avez observé l'aide peskine au
niveau du puca et des études et
recherches que vous faites de ces deux
ans ont-ils changé quelque chose alors
où ils ont notamment changer quelque
chose dans la prise de position des élus
locaux et des territoires non justement
la réorientation d'un certain nombre de
politiques publiques et je pense en
particulier à ce qu'on appelle
rapidement les circuits courts c'est à
dire la capacité à s'approvisionner dans
un territoire à proximité en tout cas
dont on maîtrise les flux les flux
d'approvisionnement et donc en réponse à
ce qui avait déjà été reconnu au début
du coc vide la fermeture des frontières
et donc la difficulté à s'approvisionner
et ça a très rapidement comme d'autres
crises comme la crise de l'énergie ça
provoque l'obligation de la
transformation l'obligation d'une
nouvelle forme d'action publique qui va
chercher de l'innovation c'est
exactement ce que vous disiez à
l'instant je pense en particulier sur
l'alimentation comme les collectivités
publiques deviennent des acteurs de
développement agricole sur les matières
premières pour la construction par
exemple comment aussi oger les effets
sociaux des pénuries ou des prix des
carburants évidemment sur les mobilités
mais aussi sur le chauffage par exemple
avec des politiques entrer dans le débat
énergétique et donc c'est un déclencheur
d'action un peu nécessaire immédiatement
indispensable pour certains les plus
précaires qui font que des acteurs
publics se mobilisent pour des
politiques qui pouvait avant être plus
regardées à une échelle plus tôt de la
planification nationale et donc de leur
ville vers nationales merci ville
durable ou villes vulnérables sébastien
meurant font qu avec cette crise ces
deux crises une ville durable une ville
qui a pris conscience de ces
vulnérabilités
pour répondre à votre question en
premier lieu bien connaître les
vulnérabilités mais par rapport à la
question que vous posiez
si on applique la pensée même de la
résilience on doit profiter de ces
événements dramatiques une pandémie une
guerre pour apprendre parce que
malheureusement les pandémies les
guerres les crises sur les matières
premières les crises migratoires c'est
l'horizon qui se dessine avec le
dérèglement climatique notamment mais
pas que donc on sait qu'il y aura
d'autres crises sur les matières
premières qui aura d'autres crises sur
l'énergie qui aura d'autres pandémies
pas par exemple on sait que les
moustiques avec le dérèglement
climatique migrent plus vite au nord que
leur miracle que leurs prédateurs par
exemple donc si on est dans une logique
de résilience et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'il se passe sur les territoires c'est
ça qui est intéressant de constater
s'exporta naiman les territoires sont
résilients nous devons à la fois gérer
la crise les crises leurs conséquences
et en même temps apprendre de ces
événements disruptif nouveau qui était
encore pas arriver sur nos territoires
pour faire évoluer nos processus nos
visions nos organisations pour être plus
forts au moment où des crises du type du
même type vont se reproduire parce
qu'évidemment elle se reproduire ne
s'agit pas d' et anxiogène ça j'ai pas
dit d'autres collapse là où je ne sais
quoi il s'agit d'être réaliste et
simplement de dire que la résilience et
les protectrices
c'est quelque chose qui permet de
protéger nos territoires nous aimons pas
ancrée dans le vif du sujet puisque nous
avons deux élus est ici est intéressant
de savoir ce que vous avez fait
concrètement dans deux domaines
essentiels à la fois la rénovation
énergétique des logements et la
décarbonation des transports est ce que
ces dernières années c'est sur ces deux
plans là que vous avez orienté
essentiellement votre action c'est pas
que ces dernières années ce que dans un
département comme le mien il y à une
association formidable je parle de
l'isolation thermique
et des énergies renouvelables qui
fonctionne depuis une cinquantaine
d'années que le département toujours
aidé et qui s'appelle l'asder
l'association savoyarde de développement
des énergies renouvelables et c'est un
vrai travail de 50 ans donc on n'a pas
découvert il ya trois ans mais vous avez
accélérer les actions en accélère les
actions il faut saluer aussi ce que fait
l'état et france rénove qui est une très
bonne initiative et on a encore beaucoup
de marge de progression
bien évidemment notamment puisqu'on un
département touristique dans ce qu'on
appelle les lits froids puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de logements qui ne sont plus
vraiment sur le marché locatif qui sont
encore utilisés mais qui pour beaucoup
d'entre eux sont de vraies passoires
thermiques ce sont des résidences
secondaires
et le vrai sujet pour imposer la
rénovation et donc l'isolément thermique
et qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui d'outils
législatifs donc on bute assez vite sur
la question de la contrainte dans un
pays de liberté
c'est à dire que la contrainte
législative vous empêche d'aller le
contraire c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de
contrainte législative pour rénover tous
qu'on appelle les lits froids
touristique où ça me pose un gros
problème à la fois sur le plan des
passoires thermiques que ces logements
sont la plupart du temps et d'autre part
qu on a des mètres carrés qui ne sont
pas utilisés alors qu'il s'avérait
beaucoup mieux utile à la société s'il
était mis en location plutôt que de
toujours construire des programmes
immobiliers nouveau et ça c'est un
problème qui est partout en france sur
le littoral en montagne que d'autres
pays ne connaisse pas parce qu'ils n'ont
pas la même structure
du droit de la propriété que nous je
pense à un pays comme le danemark
notamment et que ce sont souvent des
pays moins touristique que ne l'est de
la france donc là il ya un vrai sujet
législatif sur lequel je me suis
beaucoup épuisée quand j'étais encore
parlementaire mais pour l'instant on n'a
pas encore trouvé la bonne solution et
vous avez le même problème en normandie
lors de manière un petit peu différente
mais c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui
est identifié au plan national moi je
voulais vous remercier pour cette
question sur la sobriété et la
rénovation thermique des logements ce
que sans faire de polémique ou de
commentaires trop rapide sur la campagne
présidentielle chacun aura son analyse
on a beaucoup parlé finalement de
production d'énergie et le petit
scientifique que je suis vous dira quand
même que la première énergie
renouvelable c'est elle qu'on consomme
pas c'est un truisme mais c'est quand
même quelque chose qui n'a pas du tout
été abordée or on est face à un mur un
mur financier et un mur technique de
moyens humains pour pouvoir rénover les
logements collectifs d'ailleurs sociaux
etc on retrouve la dimension sociale à
laquelle je faisais allusion tout à
l'heure et puis privé parce que pour les
privés même si c'est vrai qu'il ya des
dispositifs qui existent et qui sont
très performants souvent quand même
quand vous êtes privé ou si vous êtes
dans une copropriété privée vous êtes
arrêté au départ parce que il ya une
barrière à l'entrée qui est certes
diminué mais qui est quand même complexe
un dossier compliqué et il ya un montant
de travaux aoun une somme a engagé au
départ
donc là il ya un mur et vraiment je
pense que sur le mandat qui vient on a
un enjeu avec l'état pour les
collectivités de financer et de
faciliter les démarches pour pouvoir
accélérer parce que c'est vrai que des
dispositifs existent à rouen on a fait
un guichet unique comme dans plein
d'autres territoires avec tous les
acteurs pour faciliter la rénovation
thermique etc on met ensemble les
bailleurs sociaux on travaille ensemble
très bien on va pas assez vite on va pas
assez vite et et personne ne va assez
vite en france donc là dessus il faut
absolument qu'on axel et puis votre
question portait aussi sur les mobilités
si je peux en dire un mot très
rapidement sur la décarbonation des
mobilités on va en parler dans le
carbone agirons vraiment merci de poser
cette question parce que personne n'en
parle alors que c'est probablement un
des plus gros mur financier pour les
collectivités locales et pour les
particuliers demain oui alors une pause
qui ne vous est prise à défaut la voyez
des élus disent que ça va pas assez vite
parce que est à la fois ça manque de
moyens financiers il n'y a pas de vraie
réglementation
comment ça se fait je crois que je sais
pas si on peut dire ça de cette manière
là il ya beaucoup depuis c'est pas le
dernier gouvernement depuis une
quinzaine d'années depuis le grenelle de
l'environnement il ya beaucoup de
démarches qui ont été entreprises pour
accélérer la rénovation énergétique des
logements et beaucoup d'outils qui ont
été mises en place alors justement un
peu trop pendant un temps ça tellement
foisonner les guichets ont différents
les financements étaient différents
certains étaient gérés par des crédits
d'impôts d'autre part des aides directes
aux ménages etc je pense
qu'effectivement dans la dernière
période on a réussi à peu près à
rassembler tous ces outils aujourd'hui
on n'atteint pas nos objectifs mais en
tout cas on a donné un peu de clarté à
tous ces dispositifs la difficulté après
c'est qu'on est face à des gens qui font
des arbitrages financiers des gens comme
vous et moi qui ont des charges impayées
par ailleurs des études pour leurs
enfants avec eux quand on leur demande
un effort financier même s'il est en
partie pris en charge par l'est par
l'état ou par les pouvoirs publics il
faut y consentir et quand le prix de
l'énergie ne permet pas cet arbitrage
favorable à des travaux qui sont
tellement d'investissement parce que
finalement on se dit qu'on peut
surmonter la crise ont fait pas cet
exercice de calcul à long terme enfin
très peur en tout cas pas comme un
gestionnaire de patrimoine immobilier
peut le faire à l'échelle de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de mètres carrés de
bureaux par exemple et donc c'est en
fait des décisions très individuelle
alors c'est encore plus difficile dans
les faits dans les copropriétés qui est
une communauté et qui sont des
communautés d'individus mais c'est aussi
difficile pour un particulier qui
doivent prendre cette décision selon son
agent plus l'intérêt pour lui
l'amortissement financier n'est pas
aussi évident notamment pour les
personnes âgées et donkey la citation ne
suffit pas nécessairement c'est aussi
pour ça que le rôle des collectivités
locales comme gars ont un peu de
proximité de ses objectifs nationaux est
absolument est une question est ce qu'il
y a deux grandes distorsions
sur la question à la fois de l'isolation
des logements d'une région à une autre
d'une ville autre est ce qu'il ya des
compos établir un classement par exemple
et à quoi c'est dû c'est à dire quand ça
va beaucoup mieux est ce que c'est parce
que c'est les édiles locaux qui font le
travail ou parce qu'ils ont plus
d'influencé au niveau du gouvernement
peut-être sébastien mer qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait dire la
section c'est qu'on a pris beaucoup de
retard sur cette question de rénovation
des logements au cours des décennies
passées
les ou des retards parador de renoir sur
la ligne européen par rapport à ce qu'il
faudrait faire au regard de l'enjeu je
vais pas faire un comparatif européen
mais 80% pour donner juste un chiffre 80
% du bâti qui sera dans notre pays en
2050 quand on aura des canicules qui
pourront durer un mois qui pourrait être
beaucoup plus forte qu'aujourd'hui il
est déjà là or ça fait 20 ans que une
majorité des crédits de l'énergie de
l'innovation ont été mis sur le fait de
rendre les nouveaux bâtiments neufs
ultras efficient avec des capteurs etc
rade mais quelque part c'est 20 %
restants c'est pas l'enjeu l'enjeu
majeur c'est le stock c'est ce qui est
déjà là ça tombe bien c'est un
magnifique vivier de création d'emplois
et cette mutation des emplois et des
compétences à l'échelle de chaque
territoire sur les filières de matériaux
biosourcés sont des nouveaux emplois
sont des nouvelles filières a créé on
commence tout juste ça aurait été bien
de le faire il ya vingt ans c'est ne
revenons pas dans le passé en tout cas
aujourd'hui il étend largement temps est
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
on est sûr de la création d'emplois
d'activités économiques vertueuse qui va
à la fois répondre aux objectifs de
qualité de vie des habitants les
passoires thermiques c'est d'abord aussi
pour les gens qui vivent dedans un
problème de qualité de vie et de coût ou
au quotidien et en même temps servir les
grands objectifs de lutte contre les
effets de l'anthropocène oui il complété
c'est très important ce qui veut dire
sébastien merde c'est que pour former
aussi les professionnels à ces emplois
nouveaux il faut du temps donc on a
aussi depuis en gros depuis le grenelle
de l'environnement je reviens mais en
gros depuis une quinzaine d'années met
en place tout un tas d'outils de
certification des artisans etc qui
prennent aussi un certain temps à se
mettre en place dont je dirais pas qu
enfin effectivement on n'a pas atteint
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés en termes
de nombre de logements rénovés chaque
année 500 mille logements rénovés chaque
année c'est un objectif qu'on s'est
fixée depuis des dizaines d'années à
l'atteindre et pour autant on essaie un
peu d'ajouter chaque fois des jalons
supplémentaires pour y arriver et s'en
approcher mais je pense que le le
passage à l'acte vraiment le un des
mieux noeud du problème c'est le
déclenchement de la décision de travaux
par le propriétaire du logement ça
marche mieux avec des gros propriétaires
comme sont les bailleurs sociaux par
exemple qui ont été beaucoup soutenu
aussi pour faire des rénovations du parc
social comme ce sont des citoyens
individuellement qu'ils doivent faire ce
choix la question est plus délicate
j'ajoute que oui les citoyens un
propriétaire privé
changer des fenêtres ça peut représenter
entre
six mois et 18 mois de loyer un donc que
ce soit pour le propriétaire pour le
locataire ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est pas un choix neutre en
termes d'arbitrage avec un budget qui
est forcément contraint et même après
les aides publiques ou locales ou des
défiscalisations ça reste un coût très
élevé mais nicolas meyer signori je
voulais rebondir parce qu'elle assure
cet exemple très concret peut-être très
technique quelque chose de très
fondamentales sur le sujet de cette
émission c'est hélène peskine à parler
de l'arbitrage les crises sanitaires le
cren mettre la pression sur l'arbitrage
l'arbitrage de la dépense publique
l'arbitrage de la dépense privée et la
grande difficulté
c'est de faciliter l'arbitrage en
rendant acceptable des choses qui ne le
serait peut-être pas sinon et pour un
ménage aujourd'hui mais ils font pas les
travaux parce qu'il ya trop avancé au
départ tout simplement tout simplement
tant qu'on n'aura pas un mécanisme qui
met 0 au départ vous n'avez rien à
avancer au départ ben on aura un effet
si vous voulez de pression de l'urgence
j'ai d'autres choses à faire j'ai
d'autres dépenses a à gérer et je remet
à plus tard sauf que on n'a plus le
temps pour plus tard on a parlé du
logement sur la décarbonation des
transports est-ce que ça va assez vite
peut-être une dernière chose sur
logement il ya le sujet majeur des
copropriétés quand il faut changer un
chauffage au fuel
qui est qui et le sujet typique c'est
extrêmement co déjà pour un particulier
de changer sa chaudière c'est déjà un
énorme investissement mais dans une
copropriété dans laquelle il ya un
chauffage collectif c'est un énorme
problème interrogés les syndics ou les
gestionnaires de biens ils vous diront
que le plus souvent il suffit que
quelques propriétaires
occupants s'y oppose pour que rien ne se
fasse donc il y a quand même aujourd'hui
des blocages systémique qu'il faut faire
sauter alors sur la question de la
décarbonation des transports bien
évidemment la question se pose
différemment selon les territoires quand
on est dans un territoire urbain comme
dans dans rouen et son agglomération
c'est pas la même chose que dans un
département comme le mien ou sertis à la
conurbation bientôt chambéry aix les
bains ou d'ailleurs nous travaillons
activement tous ensemble mais où la
l'immense majorité de mon territoire ce
sont des montagnes des vallées où la
question ne se pose pas de la même façon
alors là on développe évidemment les
itinéraires cyclables y compris pour les
trajets domicile travail pour les
collèges ont fait la même chose pour que
les élèves et des enseignants et le
personnel des collèges puissent venir à
vélo collège et le mettre dans des
conditions sécurisées mais quand vous
êtes dans de l'habitat dispersé
et j'ajoute rural et montagnard
forcément vous avez beaucoup plus besoin
de la voiture individuelle que dans un
territoire urbain et aujourd'hui on a
beau faire tout ce qu'on peut pour
faciliter ce transport décarbonés dans
les territoires ruraux disperser les
problématiques sont très très difficile
à résoudre hélène pasquet entendu un
savoyard est rond né qui disent qu'ils
font ce qu'ils peuvent est ce que vous
pensez vous que l'état fait assez à la
fois en termes de financement en termes
de décentralisation pour leur faciliter
le job
alors je pense qu'il faut regarder la
question de la mobilité à la fois sous
l'angle des mobilités choisies et des
mobilités subissent effectivement si on
prend les déplacements domicile travail
en france à peu près sont 10% qui se
font en voiture et dès qu'on sort des
villes-centres en périphérie de ville
même de villes moyennes on n'est pas ce
85 90 % donc on a un énorme au gap à
passer si on veut réduire les pollutions
et les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
liées à ces mobilités une partie de la
réponse à la prise en charge en partie
par l'état avec la fiscalité ou des
aides à la conversion des véhicules vers
des véhicules plus propres qui pose
d'autres questions en termes de filières
industrielles notamment les véhicules
électriques mais non en tout cas
l'approvisionnement en énergie doit
pouvoir être garanti en france mais ça
ne couvrira qu'une partie et finalement
de la question et du problème est donc
une autre des réponses allaient plutôt
dans l'aménagement selon moi c'est à
dire de la capacité à réduire les
kilomètres parcourus on a constaté
pendant le confinement qu'une partie de
la population pouvait travailler de chez
elle même si on ne souhaite pas
forcément que ça se développe outre
mesure mais voilà donc ça de fait ça
réduit le nombre de kilomètres parcourus
ça réduit la facture de carburant il ya
d'autres réflexions autour du
rapprochement d'un certain nombre de
fonctions des territoires très
résidentiel qui pourrait accueillir un
peu plus de deux commerces ou
d'équipements pour travailler en dehors
de chez soi ou de ou de service public
al'inverse des territoires créer des
destinations comme les zones
commerciales dont on commence aussi à
réfléchir à la fonction est la mixité
des fonctions est en fait tout ça visant
pas à transformer le type de mobilité
mais le nombre de kilomètres
nécessairement parcouru par les ménages
qui sont effectivement le captif de ce
mode de transport et la ville en france
et les territoires alors je m'en étais
dessiner pour les voitures donc depuis
50 ans on a construit une france de la
voiture donc il va falloir reculé par
rapport à cette vision du territoire qui
permettait aux gens rapidement se
déplacer d'un point à neutre avec un
carburant qui était en tout cas
considéré comme abordable pour la
majorité des ménages français et je
pense que les crises qu'on vit
aujourd'hui
cynthia fleury qui disait du confinement
convives et con con qu'on était dans une
expérience de la crise systémique avec
tout d'un coup un système qui étaient
brouillées par rapport aux codes qu'on a
habituellement ces différentes crises du
carburant et des coûts du carburant ont
les compense avec des aides publiques
beaucoup en ce moment et heureusement
parce que sinon il y aurait beaucoup de
victimes mais il faut qu on vraiment
qu'on construit à partir de là à une
vision différente de la manière dont on
se déplace aujourd'hui l'un pays en
europe et dans les pays occidentaux en
général c'est ce que vous pensez tout à
fait leur applique la sobriété à la
mobilité la meilleure mobilité
décarbonée c'est celle qu'on a pas fait
c'est exactement le même principe que
pour l'énergie donc après quelques
décennies là aussi où on considérait qu
être vertueux c'était se déplacer
toujours plus loin plus vite mais de
manière verte et qu'on a fait le constat
que ça ne marche pas il faut faire
marche arrière en me disant que éviter
des déplacements suivi obligatoire du
pendulaire etc ça peut être un levier
mais y ait un deuxième levier important
pour la décarbonation sert questionner
notre rapport à la technologie au regard
du de la disponibilité énergétique en
baisse si je vous prends un exemple
concret pour déplacer deux tonnes de suv
ou d'un gros véhicule aujourd'hui un
véhicule centre in town 5
l'énergie qui est utilisé elle déplace
les 60 kg du conducteur ou elle déplace
les hinton simple de boîte qui est
autour c'est le coeur du sujet il faut
qu'on comme dirait bruno latour ont ré
atterrissent dans le monde réel c'est à
dire un monde sans fossiles ça fait pas
si longtemps qu'on a découvert le
fossile est par ailleurs le fossile
samba donc il faut ré atterrir et si je
donne un exemple très concret je cite un
projet en cours d'expérimentation
aujourd'hui dans la communauté
d'agglomération de la rochelle qui
s'appelle le projet avatar et qui créent
et partant du principe qu'en zone rurale
on pourra pas se passer de voiture
prenons en acte c'est normal oui on
pourra pas des transports en commun
partout c'est pas vrai on a construit la
france autrement faut s'adapter à moi il
craint pour un projet en cours
d'expérimentation où on a un véhicule le
véhicule du futur est ce que c'est une
voiture volante ultra technologique etc
ou est ce que c'est un vélo électrique à
deux places avec une boîte autour qui
projette des qui protège des intempéries
et qui pèse à peine 100 kg 150 kg ce qui
fait que leur apport énergétique est
excellent et ça peut être utilisée par
ailleurs avec un coût de production
parfaitement accessible quel que soit
son revenu quel que soit son niveau
qu'il ya des solutions donc on a des
solutions nicolas mayer rossignol / se
brouille alors je vais être un tout
petit peu polémique je partage
évidemment l'idée que pour le coup sur
les mobilités la décarbonation beaucoup
a été fait côté de l'état du côté des
collectivités qui à part une solution
qui convienne à tout le monde qu en
fonction évidemment des typologies de
territoire des déplacements des deux là
où vous habitez vous avez plus avoir
besoin du vélo des transports en commun
etc externe tout cela est tout à fait
juste mais un là encore comme pour la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments est
ce que le rythme le rythme de la
décarbonation est conforme avec nos
objectifs c'est à dire l'accord de paris
un peu c'est ça notre objectif de 2015
et renouveler et même améliorer encore
un récemment pour la france en tout cas
et puis pour l'union européenne non le
rythme on n'y est pas donc il faut aller
encore plus vite et ça ça veut dire plus
d'argent et plus alors vous l'avez dit
aussi plus de moyens techniques et
humains faut vraiment insister là dessus
c'est pas juste une question d'argent
d'ingénierie humaines et techniques pour
mettre en place le réseau cyclable pour
mettre en place l'aménagement on parle
du zéro artificialisation net
l'aménagement de l'agglomération du
quart d'heure ou du territoire du quart
d'heure pour éviter des déplacements
inutiles et puis un deuxième élément un
peu polémique c'est qu'il faut aussi
dire ce à quoi on renonce
parce que la mobilité la décarbonation
des mobilités c'est aussi dire ce qu'on
ne fera plus vous construisez encore des
autoroutes ou pas
vous faites plus sur le train ou plus
sur la route on parle des passagers mais
le fret aussi moi je suis sur un axe qui
est l'axé seine paris rouen le havre
sans marchandises 85 passe par camion
85 sur son et vous en avez à l'e10 sur
le fleuve et cinq sur le train les
meilleurs ports d'europe qui sont les
ports d'europe du nord hambourg
rotterdam anvers et ses 40% minimum
passe par le train ou le fleuve
ils sont meilleurs sur le plan
économique y sont meilleures sur plan
écologique mais évidemment il ya des
choix à faire et en termes
d'investissements je vais mettre un
accent sur le train parce que si vous
prenez le train pour aller en normandie
vous savez de quoi je veux parler mais à
vrai dire nous ne sommes pas les seuls
dans cette situation c'est difficile
vous avez pro tgv non mais c'est même
pas une question de tgv nous le savez on
est le normand n'est assez modeste 1
euro de l'heure et râleur et des trains
fréquents ça nous irait très bien non
c'est pas une question de tgv mais par
contre investir beaucoup plus sur le
train pour les passagers et le fret
aujourd'hui on n'est pas au niveau et là
encore c'est une question de rythme et
de choix parce que dans les arbitrages
dans la résilience il y à aussi dirai
peut-être que ça manque un tout petit
peu à nous et je fais j'en prends ma
part de responsabilité il ya aussi le
coût d'opportunité et de dire ce qu'on
ne fera plus de ce conte hervé gaymard
une question un peu indiscrètes par
rapport à la discussion que nous avons
est ce que ces problèmes
écologiques d'aménagement du territoire
entre ville et ses métropoles est ce que
ça marche mieux quand on a plus
d'influencé ministériel et c'est ce qui
explique que certaines villes sont plus
avancés dans ce domaine que d'autres
enfin je crois que ça dépend d'eux
est-ce que ça on a quand on a le bras
long est ce que ça marche mieux je pense
que ça dépend de l'esprit d'initiative
d'imagination et j'allais dire
d'unification de toutes les énergies
d'un territoire élus associations
professionnelles pour avancer puisque
vous parliez de la question du fret
dans ma région au delà même de mon
département on a un sujet emblématique
qui est la liaison fret
lyon turin d'ailleurs improprement
appelée lyon turin parce que le sujet
c'est que c'est un corridor européen
pour éviter que les marchandises reste
sur les camions mais aille sur le rail
il ya une première étape qui est en
train d'être réalisés c'est un tunnel
international entre la vallée de la
maurienne entre qui est discutée yens
oui mais il est en train de se faire et
on sait qu'il sera en fonction en 2030
c'est maintenant une certitude donc qui
reliera la vallée de la maurienne au val
de suse en italie seul problème c'est
que les accès entre lyon et saint jean
de maurienne pour l'instant ne sont pas
décidés c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé
dans en angleterre pour le tunnel sous
la manche ou le tunnel a été fait et il
a fallu attendre ce n'est pas 15 ans 20
ans pour que les accès se fasse de la
sortie à folkestone pour aller jusqu'à
londres mais là c'est un peu la même
chose on attendait une décision
gouvernementale au premier trimestre de
cette année 2022 plusieurs scénarios
étaient retenus par une commission après
beaucoup de concertation et donc on
avait l'engagement du gouvernement
qu'une décision serait prise avant la
fin du premier trimestre sur le choix du
tracé
ce choix n'a pas été fait et je le
regrette beaucoup parce que il faut agir
sans tarder parce que sur ces grands
équipements structurants l'offre crée la
demande alors les opposants disent
évidemment actuellement il n'y a pas
grand chose sur le train c'est beaucoup
sur sur le camion tout ça est
inévitable et fatale moi je crois au
contraire que l'offre crée la demande et
qu'il faut que les grandes
infrastructures soit à niveau pour
permettre cette décarbonation du
transport merci hélène peskine parce
qu'elle est vraiment intéressant avec
ces deux exemples et vous prononciez le
terme d'aménagement du territoire il ya
effectivement des articulations
d'échelle qui sont très importantes
entre deux décisions qui relèvent du
niveau européen ou national notamment
ses grands axes l'axé seine la traversée
des fonctions que l'europe et y 50 %
jouent coupe une sombre et l'union
européenne paye 50 % des travaux oui et
les grands territoires par exemple si on
vers le souvent et c'est ça ce sont des
questions à l'échelle du territoire
national de territoire disons
d'importance stratégique on va le dire
comme ça notamment dans ces temps de
transition on l'a vu le passage sur le
train du parti de la mobilité le passage
sur le fleuve ou la transformation
industrielle on a peu parlé mais d'un
monde industriel de lacq social qui est
très carbonées aussi et là je trouve
qu'on touche au débat qui est de savoir
quel est le rôle de l'état et quel est
le rôle des territoires dans ces actions
qui sont à la fois supra territoriale et
inter territoriale il faut aussi qu'elle
s'articule entre eux les gouvernance
locale qui sont celles élus localement
par origine il est essentiel que ça se
passe bien pour que les projets
aboutissent puis-je aussi évoqué et
brille un sujet bah c'est un autre tube
d'un sujet industriel très important en
terme de coordination nous avons la
chance en savoie d'avoir eu jitec qui
est le leader mondial de l'acier
inoxydable et cette usine avec l'aide
des collectivités et en cédant elle-même
on va faire deux percées dans les temps
qui viennent la première c'est que
désormais grâce au département l
intercommunalité on a repris une voie
que vous les délaisser la sncf pour que
tout arrive en train ce qui arrive est
ce qui ressort de lusine et la deuxième
chose c'est que à horizon 2030 c'est
demain lusine d'ugine fonctionnera avec
100% d'acier recyclé alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est 50% de minerais qui
vient de l'autre bout du monde donc ça
aussi ce sont des révolutions qui
peuvent paraître minuscule mais qui sont
très importantes merci
[Musique]
alors passons maintenant si je puis dire
au volet européen
en ce qui concerne la transition
énergétique l'union européenne s'est
préoccupée de la sécurité alimentaire
elle vient d'accorder 500 millions
d'euros aux agriculteurs les plus
exposés est-ce que c'est suffisant et
est-ce que vous pensez que l'europe fait
assez de choses dans ce domaine
sébastien mer
moi quand vous posez la question de la
sécurité alimentaire
j'ai d'abord envie de répondre
territoire et locale avant de répondre
europe parce qu'on voit bien que la
mondialisation
l'europe alimentaire devient une source
de vulnérabilité pour
l'approvisionnement des territoires
parce qu'on a des chaînes logistiques à
rallonge entre cinq ou six endroits
stratégiques qui sont extrêmement
vulnérables non seulement à des guerres
mais à des événements climatiques à des
grèves à etc etc il ya un travail qui a
été il ya plusieurs travaux qui ont été
construits qui sont très intéressants
sur le lien entre résilience alimentaire
et sécurité publique et ordre public je
citerais notamment stéphane linou qui a
beaucoup écrit sur ce sujet c'est victor
hugo à 10 entre le la démocratie à la
barbarie à 5 repas et donc on réalise à
l'occasion du coc vie depuis décrit sur
l'approvisionnement en matières
premières alimentaires liées à la guerre
en ukraine à quel point on est
vulnérable à quel point on a perdu en
quelques décennies à peine la capacité
de nourrir la population localement
comme on l'a fait pendant des
millénaires quand même donc le progrès
nous a créé des vulnérabilités
aujourd'hui qui sont extrêmement
dangereux il met au niveau européen au
niveau européen je crois que l'europe
vient de libérer quatre millions et demi
d'hectares et
de jachères pour permettre de rattraper
un petit peu cette sécurité à lima lors
ce n'est pas exactement le projet dont
vous parlez mais si la logique c'est à
dire pour renforcer la sécurité
alimentaire aujourd'hui il faut repartir
dans l'agriculture industrielle comme on
l'a fait en après guerre et dont on
entend tellement aujourd'hui de faire
marche arrière vu les externalités
négatives moi j'ai tant que je
connaissais pas le projet en particulier
j'ai tendance à penser que si l'europe
devait soutenir la résilience
alimentaires des territoires il faudrait
plutôt qu'elles financent des programmes
locaux sur les territoires partout en
europe pour recréer ces ceintures
maraîchères telles qu'elles ont pu
exister avant et c'est plutôt que 2 de
créer des installations agricoles
industrielles dont on sait qu'elles
créent tellement de problèmes par
ailleurs sur l'atteinte aux limites
planétaires qu'elles sont neuf pas être
la solution du du de la solution du
siècle de rawdon peskine oui alors je
suis convaincu aussi que la
spécialisation des terres agricoles
comme elle s'est développée dans toute
l'europe avec des terres spécialisées
dans les céréales d'autres dans le
maraîchage entre le sud et le nord de
l'europe ça correspond pas effectivement
la nécessité de retrouver sans être
évidemment autosuffisant parle pas de
d'être complètement fermé à signer dans
un territoire donné mais en tout cas de
retrouver une capacité d'abord à savoir
ce que l'on mange comment il a été
produit s'il est constitué d'un matériau
si je puis dire unique du matière
première et unique ou d'un mélange de
matières premières ce qu'on voit quand
même dans l'industrie agroalimentaire
qui a énormément des changes avec des
pays en dehors de l'europe 1 dans la
confection des produits agroalimentaires
et donc effectivement il ya d'abord une
attente citoyenne qui s'est beaucoup
développée pendant le coc vide de savoir
ce que l'on mange concrètement la
traçabilité on l'avait vu à l'époque de
la crise de la vache folle aussi c'est
celle des choses très naturel que les
gens s'interrogent de savoir ce qu'on
met dans leur assiette et donc on a de
plus en plus d'attentes des
consommateurs vis-à-vis de la qualité
alimentaire et donc il faut aussi
trouver les réponses et une partie des
collectivités la grande majorité même
des collectivités petites ou grandes
commence à travailler sa réponse depuis
quelques années donc ça avec moi aussi
tendance à penser que le le retour à une
agriculture qui serait très régulée à
administrer
plutôt de nature intensives avec les
outils comme on était celui de la pâte
pendant des décennies ne vient pas
tellement dans le sens de la
facilitation d'une résilience
alimentaire si on laisse de côté hervé
gaymard démagogie écologique est ce que
finalement on est quand même un pays où
il ya une sécurité alimentaire en france
alors le dire par rapport parce qu'il
faut quand même toujours se comparer aux
voisins est-ce que non c'est un sujet
qui mériterait une émission à sony
aurait d'ailleurs publié il ya quelques
mois un rapport sur la souveraineté
alimentaire
dans le cadre de l'institut montaigne
qui est téléchargeable sur le site de
l'institut montaigne qu'on a appelée en
campagne pour l'agriculture de demain et
en espérant que ce sujet sera au coeur
des débats présidentiels mais ça n'a pas
été le cas mais le rapport reste quand
même je pense intéressant je pense qu'il
sait pas
il faut pas avoir une vision binaire de
cette question
première remarque oui il faut développer
la territorialisation de l'agriculture
il y a beaucoup de plans alimentaires
territoriaux qui se développe un peu
partout en france moi même en savoie je
mène avec tous les partenaires un plan
alimentaire et agricole
départemental ou une des questions
principales d'ailleurs à la question
foncière
comment porter le foncier pour installer
notamment dans le maraîchage dont vous
parliez dans les ceintures vertes
comment pouvoir installer de nouveaux
agriculteurs
en les exonérant de la charge foncière
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais c'est des sujets sur lesquels il ya
énormément d'innovation et beaucoup de
choses qui se passent ça oui mais faut
pas être caricatural c'est pas les
carottes dans le jardin pour résumer qui
résoudront la question il ya évidemment
une dimension européenne est une des
mères ancion mondiale au plan européen
en allant vite je suis assez content des
évolutions qui se dessine parce que
maintenant c'est vieux il ya eu à peu
près une vingtaine d'années j'étais
ministre d'agriculture
et à l'époque à bruxelles à part des
pays comme l'italie ou le portugal ou
l'espagne qui était ou l'irlande qui
était sur notre ligne d'une agriculture
familiale des territoriales c'était le
grand vent de l'om c'est de la
mondialisation dans un débat m'a dit un
jour mais pourquoi vouloir produire en
europe regardez on peut acheter partout
sur les marchés mondiaux
cette naïveté et 7 irénisme c'est fini
et bien fini et ça c'est une très bonne
chose mais un troisième sujet qu'il faut
pas négliger qui est celui de
l'alimentation et de l'agriculture en
afrique puisque le véritable sujet à
l'horizon 2050 déjà maintenant on le
voit bien avec la sphère ukrainiennes et
russes et l'absence de blé pour les pays
du maghreb et d'afrique mais la
véritable question
alimentaire elle est également africaine
comment on arrive à développer
l'agriculture africaine dans un contexte
de réchauffement
climatique qui crée plein de difficultés
voilà un bel enjeu pour l'union
européenne puisque c'est au croisement
de la politique agricole européenne de
sa politique commerciale et également de
sa politique de développement donc c'est
un sujet absolument capital je m'étonne
que à part quelques initiés personne
n'en parle et l'avenir de l'agriculture
africaine c'est aussi notre avenir il
faut vraiment en être persuadé or et
nicolas mayer rossignol vous lire réagir
là-dessus oui parce que vous posez la
question de l'europe est effectivement
d'abord l'europe comme affirmation d'une
puissance internationale la question
derrière c'est quelle est sa place dans
le monde et juste pour donner un chiffre
le nombre de personnes en insécurité
alimentaire dans ce monde tel que nous
le vivons aujourd'hui il augmente il
augmente chaque année et l'augmenter dès
qu'on a de plus en plus de gens en
valeur absolue qui n'ont pas assez à
manger et effectivement on nous parlait
dans le monde mais dans le jeu peine je
commence par le monde parce
qu'effectivement elle je pense qu'avec
démarre à raison de placer l'europe à ce
niveau là si l'europe veut s'affirmer
comme une puissance internationale alors
son rôle c'est aussi de porter ces
sujets là et quand on à moi je ne me
résous pas quand on a un nombre de
personnes qui meurent de faim qui
augmente dans cette société mondiale
c'est qu'on a un problème et en plus
juste pour donner quelques chiffres
quand même pour sauver un enfant de la
malnutrition aiguë sévère il faut 50
euros 50 euros c'est pas beaucoup 50
euros et pourtant on n'y arrive pas
c'est à dire qu'on a de plus en plus
d'enfants qui sont atteints de
malnutrition aiguë sévère en afrique
mais pas seulement en afrique en
amérique du sud au yémen dont personne
ne parle alors que c'est une famine
épouvantable dans de nouveaux théâtres
de conflits en afrique notamment
l'ethiopie par exemple ou l'erythrée en
asie du sud est donc l'europe elle a
d'abord ce rôle là ensuite effectivement
et à ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure et
bien sûr que l'europe a un rôle social
d'accompagnement sur le changement de
mode d'agriculture en europe mais vous
savez l'europe c'est d'abord l'europe
des européens et comme l'a dit hélène
peskine les européens aujourd'hui il se
tourner parce qu'ils ont accès à plus
d'informations parce qu'il ya aussi des
directives européennes pour le coût en
termes de sécurité alimentaire de
sécurité fabrication des produits sur
les produits chimiques les
néonicotinoïdes jugera blessés mais ils
se tournent vers des produits et des
cours je vous ai entendu là-dessus je
vais vous donner la parole sébastien mer
mais juste en deux mots
rouen était dans l'actualité il ya deux
ans avec la sphère lubrizol
brièvement en matière de sécurité
industrielle vous avez fait beaucoup de
choses à ce niveau là on réfléter que ça
se reproduise on a fait beaucoup de
choses mais je vais vous voulez une
réponse sans langue de bois ou avec
landon sans langue de bois la sécurité
industrielle c'est une prérogative de
l'état donc je vais pas vous dire que la
mairie ou la métropole en normandie est
responsable des inspecteurs qui vont
visiter les sites industriels c'est pas
vrai celui qui est chargé de faire
respecter les directives en l'occurrence
directive seveso et c'est comme sur le
site de lubrizol mais comme sur beaucoup
d'autres un dans l'agglomération
rouennaise y en a une vingtaine dans le
sillon rhodanien par exemple y en a
beaucoup aussi bon c'est l'état c'est
l'état est-ce que les sirènes ont changé
depuis deux ans à rouen non quand mba
peyrade son penalty face à la suisse
vous recevez une notification sur votre
téléphone si vous avez une usine qui
brûlent dix mille tonnes d'hydrocarbures
dans le ciel vous avez une sirène de
1945 qui se déclenchent plus ou moins
donc je fais un peu exprès mais ce que
je vais dire est la réalité est ce que
ce qu'on appelle le cell broadcast c'est
à dire la diffusion cellulaire qui vous
donne une notification comme quand il ya
un penalty raté que vous soyez habitants
de rouen ou juste de passage à au
touriste à oran ou de n'importe où mais
étant aaron à ce moment là est-ce que ça
s'est mis en place en france n'ont ni à
rouen ni ailleurs ça serait un problème
sébastien maire vous vouliez revenir sur
la sécurité alimentaire la sécurité du
médiateur ont vraiment deux chiffres
changer de régime alimentaire
renforcerait grandement la sécurité
alimentaire et permettrait notamment de
récupérer des terres agricoles sans
avoir besoin d'artifices ya lisez en
plus c'est qu'aujourd'hui une écrasante
majorité je crois que c'est les deux
tiers des surfaces agricoles ne servent
pas à nourrir directement les humains
mais à nourrir le bétail que consomment
les humains donc si on veut à la fois
décarbonés et en même temps réduire
le vin ont renforcé la sécurité
alimentaire le changement de régime
alimentaire ça coûte rien en tout cas
aux habitants tout de suite c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
efficace deuxième chiffre là encore
recréer de l'agriculture enfin
l'agriculture industrielle intensive
elle contribue au franchissement je
crois de 7 des 9 limites planétaires
quand on parle de limites planétaires
ces l'habitabilité de la terre pour sa
pièce il faut sortir de ce modèle le
chiffre project qui a élaboré qui est un
think tank a élaboré un plan de
transformation de l'économie française
quand même bien charpenté très sérieux
chiffre à 500 milles le les emplois à
créer en france pour décarbonés
l'agriculture donc on est là encore sur
quelque chose de positif on peut à la
fois décarbonée on peut à la fois
renforcer la sécurité alimentaire à
partir au moment où on change de vision
de paradigme sur les priorités
[Musique]
nv skins
on va essayer de prolonger notre
conversation par un point intéressant la
résilience des territoires oblige
aujourd'hui à plus de gouvernance
sociale même socioculturel quelque chose
de plus participatif pour que nous
soyons plus efficaces
est ce que l'état est ce que les
territoires est ce que les individus est
ce que le puca que vous représentez elle
vous avez pris la mesure de cette
exigence citoyenne et qu'est ce que vous
faites dans ce domaine alors nous on
notre rôle 1 c2 c'est ce qu'on peut dire
c'est d'apprendre des territoires où on
installe des antennes peu partout dans
les territoires français les grandes
villes notamment mais aussi des petites
villes et aussi des villes moyennes en
revitalisation pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui se joue dans la mise
en oeuvre des politiques d'aménagement
au sens large y compris on parler
d'alimentation tout à l'heure où de
relocalisation industrielle et voir un
peu où se situe justement les freins et
leviers à partir d'objectifs nationaux
qui sont plus vraiment contester
notamment dans le sens de la transition
écologique où se situent les freins pour
agir et une dernier constat qu'on fait
depuis c'est pas tout neuf un en fait
c'est aussi issu de la philosophie du
grenelle les comités grenelle etc ça
fait quand même une dizaine quinzaine
d'années aujourd'hui que ça se met en
place c'est que rien ne se de se décrète
pas l'eau et que de toute façon alors
les élus s'ils seront plus jeune que moi
d'en parler mais systématiquement pour
convaincre il faut mobiliser pour
mobiliser il faut expliquer il faut
informer on a bien vu avec l'exemple à
l'échelle nationale la crise la
convention citoyenne sur le climat que
pour arriver à convaincre des citoyens
issu de la diversité de la population
française qu' il ya des moyens d'agir
pour le climat il fallait d'abord
pendant à peu près six ou sept séances
les documenter les informer sur les
enjeux sur la réalité des filières sur
la capacité à agir et c est donc cette
nécessité d'informer les citoyens pour
qu'ils soient prêts à agir on l'a vu sur
déjà balayé beaucoup de sujets la
qualité de ce qu'ils mangent la
performance thermique de leur logement
leur mobilité ça demande une proximité
que il me semble seuls les élus locaux
ou leurs équipes ou les opérateurs qui
sont autour d'eux peuvent peuvent mettre
à disposition est dans une relation de
proximité qui est évidente y compris j
allais chez lui d'une société locale
c'est-à-dire de caractéristiques du
territoire qui sont aussi des
caractéristiques sociales historiques
géographiques industriels ont parlé de
l'axé seine où la montagne du littoral
on n'est pas face aux mêmes défis
exactement et donc il faut aussi faire
atterrir comme il est sébastien mer
c'est politique publique appliquée au
terrain avec les gens qui auront à les
supplier où aller ou au contraire aller
à les favoriser alors ces moyens
éducatifs ses moyens d'information cette
nouvelle gouvernance
vous en êtes conscient nicolas mais
rossignol et concrètement qu'est ce que
vous faites dans ce domaine oui on est
on est effectivement confronté à cela et
c'est très positif c'est qu'il ya une
forme de baisses de paradoxes en tout
cas de façade d'un côté on sent bien que
l'abstention et cetera les nos
concitoyens se méfient ou ce défi des
politiques ou des politiciens des élus
j'en fais partie mais d'un autre côté
élite en général d'un autre côté il ya
une appétence et un intérêt pour la
politique au sens de la transformation
de la société selon ses convictions
alors ça peut être via un engagement
électif les appels d'un engagement
associatif participatif communautaire
sociétale dans les entreprises on voit
très bien dans l'engagement notamment
des jeunes générations dans leur
entreprise il ya beaucoup de questions
comme ça moi j'ai travaillé dans une
entreprise privée une pme familiale où
les recrutements nous disait mais alors
qu'est ce que vous faites pour le
territoire mais au risque peut-être là
encore de créer une petite polémique
mais je trouve que c'est un débat qui
est intéressant et c'est un élu local
qui veulent dire est-ce que c'est super
suffisant pour faire système je crois
pas je crois pas du tout je crois que ce
qui nous manque aussi hélas c'est un
rôle éminemment de l'état et de l'europe
c'est de dire ouf quelle société on
propose je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
juste dire que les territoires et ils
sont tous formidables ils ont tous leur
spécificité parce qu'il met en place on
le fait à rouen d'ailleurs vous en vaut
tard et elle vous empêche de faire un
manuel d'information de gouvernants ont
fait sept ans comme ça sauf qu'on nous
dit sauf qu'on nous dit oui tout ça
c'est très bien donc vous me demandez
par exemple on va faire un manuel vous
donner un exemple concret on fait un
manuel pour expliquer pourquoi on va
éteindre l'éclairage la nuit entre 1h et
5h du matin dans notre agglomération
dans la plupart des villes de
l'agglomération pour faire des économies
et c'est les gens vous disent ben oui
d'accord mais alors un sentiment
d'insécurité et puis surtout 2 pourquoi
nous on doit subir ça alors que vous
avez des enseignes commerciales qui
restent allumées vrai alors que vous
avez des industries qui continue pollux
à ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'on
a besoin peut-être que ça rejoint ses
concepts dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
de planification écologique d'une vision
de la france 2 où on va globalement et
ça s'étire en place votre collègue
françois rebsamen
dit que pour résoudre un peu tout ça il
s'est chargé de toutes les compétences
je voudrais vous poser une question
politique hervé gaymard
présidait le conseil général de ça moi
mais vous préside également l'institut
charles de gaulle à votre avis on parle
beaucoup d'europe des nations des
veilles des nations est ce que vous
pensez qu'on peut ça peut aider à un
éveil des territoires je pense que les
territoires en somme les veilles des
nations à l'éveil des terres et
territoires en france sont très éveillé
à trente endormi quand même s'ils n'ont
pas tous endormis endormi l'été c'est là
que les choses se passent 1 et la france
c'est au rebours de ce que disent
beaucoup de mes collègues élus est
beaucoup plus décentralisée mais qu'on
ne le pense donc il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives qui foisonnent il faut les
saluer il faut encore aller plus loin
bien éveil des territoires d'accord et
le pesquit oui mais je crois surtout
qu'il n'y a pas de divergence finalement
entre ce qu'on disait au début de cette
émission la gestion de crise la gestion
de la pénurie en énergie en carburant
etc et les politiques locales de
transition finalement elles convergent
vers à la nécessité d'être plus sobre
dans nos modes de vie et donc il faut
arriver à articuler ce qui relève d'une
planification de gros objectifs partagés
à l'échelle de la nation et d'une mise
en oeuvre à appliquer un territoire
donné dans une société de et vas-y des
territoires aussi
voir et gouvernance le cerveau un peu
barbare un pour le grand public mais il
est central dans ces questions de
transition c'est tout l'intérêt de
l'association france ville durable
l'état des collectivités des entreprises
et des experts ensemble pour essayer de
trouver des solutions parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu ni de ces catégories qui arrivera
tout seul est d'accord nicolas mas et
rossignol là-dessus faut une vision
l'état doivent fournir cette vision dire
où on veut aller il faut effectivement
ensuite rassembler fédérer les acteurs
la puissance publique seul suffit pas et
encore faut-il qu'elles se rassembler le
même les collectivités et l'état et
l'union européenne ont fait aussi les
entreprises les citoyens des
associations et puis et puis et ça je
pense que c'est un point qui est souvent
un impensé de nos débats il faut parfois
résister à la dictature du court terme
et dire aussi ce à quoi finalement on va
renoncer merci alors égoutter merci
voilà merci messieurs avoir participé à
cette émission je voudrais rappeler une
brève biographie alors hervé gaymard
vous avez publié un livre un homme en
guerre chez équateur wyss a pas beaucoup
de rapport que oui ça n'a pas beaucoup
de rapport mais c'est votre je crois
vous avez publié un autre livre qui
viennent paraître vous allez en dire
deux mots mais cet homme en guerre c'est
votre côté résistance et gaullistes qui
vous pousse à vous avez serré ternium il
s'appelle bernard fall qui est née
d'ailleurs ans qu'elle est journaliste
ailleurs qui est né dans un shuttle
d'ukraine au nord de lambert comme la
ville s'appelait à l'époque vous voyez
c'est d'actualite par là et qui a une
vie absolument formidable résistant en
france puisqu'il est arrivé en france
après l'anschluss en 38 et la nuit de
cristal et voilà c'est un parcours de
vie exceptionnel il a sauté sur une mine
au vietnam en 67 alors qu'ils étaient
universitaire de guerre et qu'ils
allaient voir sur le terrain ce qui se
passait donc j'ai fait un voyage dans
cette vie et ce livre est aussi le récit
de l'enquète voilà écoutez je vous
remercie d'avoir rappelé cette chose là
alors nicolas meyer rossignol vous avez
publié avec guillaume bachelay la gauche
après la crise chez jean paul gaultier
vite en deux mots après la crise ou
pendant la crise va la gauche est
toujours en crise si j'ai un peu
d'autodérision il faut juste préciser
que ce livre date de 2010 oui déjà à
l'époque on parlait de crise pour la
gauche si je puis me permettre de faire
ce jour et d'auto dérision oui c'était
une forme de décès sur une façon de
réinventer on l'appelle comme on veut la
social démocratie ou la social écologie
je crois qu'une effectivement ce débat
reste d'actualité parce qu'on l'a bien
vu sur ces élections présidentielles
notre monde n'est pas soutenable notre
monde tel qu'il va aujourd'hui n'est pas
soutenable vous la verrez sur des
ressources n'est sur le plan des
nouvelles inégalités donc il faut en
changer alors et n peskine toujours sur
rouen vous publiez du moins le pop su
qui dépendent du puca et qui faisait une
agence justement pour défendre toutes
les questions que nous avons abordé
aujourd'hui la métropole performative
fruit d'une collaboration de bris et
xavier dejardin donc c'est publié chez
autrement s'est affaissé une
collaboration avec la métropole de roy
un cadre de nos programmes qui sont
qu'en barque finalement des chercheurs
en sciences humaines dans les métropoles
et donc c'est le la trajectoire
métropolitaine de rouen avec son
hinterland comme on dit en tout cas son
son agglomération pour trouver un
dispositif un peu de de commandement de
ce grand territoire et avec un parcours
assez récent puisque ces deux métropoles
jeunes autour des enjeux et des
spécificités du territoire est-ce que
l'habit métropolitain fait le moine
c'est d'une certaine manière alors je
voudrais rappeler aussi la résilience
des métropoles qui est directement en
écho à notre émission de magali
tallandier publié lors la par le pop
suez plus qu'à est-ce que vous avez
publié quelque chose à ville durable
tout à fait moi je veux citer le
manifeste pour la ville durable réalisée
par l'association et ses quatre collèges
qui présente une nouvelle vision un
nouveau cap de ce qu'on considère peut
considérer aujourd'hui comme une ville
ou territoires durables particulier
autour de la sobriété la résilience
l'inclusion et la créativité donc
j'invite ces disponible sur le site de
l'association voilà un beau programme il
me reste donc à vous remercier à
remercier l'équipe des cp et je vous
laisse avec cette citation de boris
cyrulnik
la résilience et l'art de naviguer dans
les torrents avons essayé de le faire
aujourd'hui
mais sans tempête
[Musique]